we unleashed something powerful the only
chance you've got this together there is
another person I can take maybe I'm
doing it wrong you have no idea what I'm
capable of
you just wanted to give me a hug wish me
luck really
watch this
sorry I'm messing around
which I had a suit
even with like minimal powers or maybe
even just a suit with no powers yeah
everybody's surprise surprise so I do an
amen in the wast video yesterday they
decide to drop even more footage today
with a whole bunch of new stuff but a
lot of you've also been requesting
updates on the Captain Marvel movie so I
just figured I'd do that and this so
we'll talk about the new ant-man footage
then I'll talk about Captain Marvel if
you're finding me for the first time
there's a new round of that infinity war
DVD giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video I'll name a winner at the
end of this we finally get to hear the
ghost speak for the first time you have
no idea what I'm capable of so it sounds
like one of those scenarios where she's
not terrible when the movie picks up but
through her actions as ghosts through
whatever heist is going down here she
gains her powers through the quantum
realm and then just goes next level
crazy with power
pretty standard Disney Marvel
storytelling trope you have someone with
a tragic past that's been put upon their
entire life no one believed in them they
get crazy powers recipe for a villain
origin story which is why you know it's
important that Hope has like these other
people around her like her father that
cares about her Ant Man that cares about
her they actually kind of addressed that
during the first film when they were
trying to teach Scott how to control the
ants and she put the device on that
allowed her to communicate with them and
things got really dark really fast
[Music]
oh I don't know why I came in the first
place
hank pym had to scream to get her to
take it off so you could imagine what
would happen where she left to her own
devices without the support system she
have surround her like the whole idea
that some of this power could corrupt
you they kind of did that during the
first movie with the yellowjacket
character where he was driven mad by
some of the technology that they were
using like he could actually legit drive
you nuts which kind of seems like what's
going on here with the quantum realm and
ghosts like she seems like a pretty
badass person but this look on her face
here is not the look of a sane person
then obviously you have all the funny
stuff with Lois how about a suit not
even a special suit with powers just a
regular old suit no absolutely not
you're definitely not getting a suit
they've been a lot of you asking about
potential Janet Van Dyne villains story
like if she's secretly one of the
villains of the movie I don't know if
they're gonna take that dramatic left
turn but they could have a scenario
whereby she's driven a little bit nuts
by what's been happening to her wall
she's in the quantum realm and they sort
of have to bring her back to sanity it
would really be weird if she were stuck
down there in the quantum realm for 30
plus years and didn't go a little bit
crazy but I mean obviously michelle
pfeiffer great actress so she does a
really good job of walking that
tightrope of really nuts and really
badass remember her Selina Kyle in
Batman Returns like just a really
awesome
totally normal secretary type character
that was able to do the swing to this
crazy Catwoman persona
so I'm really hoping there's a little
bit of that Michelle Pfeiffer in the
film just like a little bit of her off
the chain but a lot of you been asking
about Captain Marvel they've been
filming the movie like they jump back
and forth and I talked about it in my
last video too about how she shot her
Avengers for scenes before they did the
Captain Marvel movie so I'll link that
video at the end of this but the big
thing that people have been asking me is
is who is the actual villain of the
Captain Marvel movie and I think it's
actually a bit of a surprise because
there's like four characters that could
be the villain that they've cast likely
pases Ronan the accuser is gonna be
showing up a younger version of his
character with Korath from the guardians
of the galaxy movie so they're crazy
20-plus years into the future during the
events of guardians of the galaxy but
you also have Ben Mendelsohn playing a
character that they haven't announced
yet and he typically plays really good
villains so he could either be the
supreme intelligence of the Kree he
could be the scroll Emperor but the cast
this actress as Minerva and she's sort
of a dark version of Captain Marvel like
you know not a really big character that
people know a whole lot about so I think
part of the reason for including some of
these other villains likely paces Ronan
the accuser in Ben Mendelsohn is is
because they're familiar actors like oh
I remember him from Star Wars okay I get
it I remember him from guardians of the
galaxy so in the way when they did
guardians of the galaxy they had like a
couple familiar things with a whole
bunch of weird stuff I think they're
doing the same thing with Captain Marvel
like people know who brie Larson is but
because they're doing so many new
characters I think they want to keep it
as familiar as possible so they're sort
of using Ronan the accuser and Ben
Mendelsohn as like the soft in for
people that don't know a lot about
comics like hey remember these people
yeah they're bad but really this other
person over here is gonna wind up being
the true villain of the film so if
you're not a big Captain Marvel comic
book fan it is one of the most
complicated comic book continuities
there been a bunch of different versions
of the character there's been Game of
Thrones level artificial insemination
children created it gets nuts but it
also involves characters like the
Celestials and quasar so this is where I
think they're sort of building
themselves into the Eternals movie and
the franchise that they just announced
so you can kind of see how they're
pushing into new continuity for other
movies using the
in Marvel movie so it's all about this
file of L character she's actually the
daughter of Marvel Marvel is the person
that falls in love with Carol Danvers
and gives her his powers eventually
before all that happen
Marvel fell in love with an artificial
Titan called
Elysium so she was artificially created
on the planet Titan where Thanos is from
so she was an artificially created
eternal so she had like their DNA so she
had extra superpowers she fell in love
with Marvel he eventually left went on
to other ventures and died here's where
it gets kind of complicated she left him
so much that she used leftover genetic
material from him to create two children
so file Lavelle was one of these two
children the other one the male child
became sort of the successor Captain
Marvel for a little while in the comics
he went a little bit crazy she battled
him for the title of Captain Marvel so
you get the idea
you have the Carol Danvers Captain
Marvel that takes the title eventually
but you have the real daughter of Marvel
who feels like the title belongs to her
so you can see why she might hate Carol
Danvers and want to take her power from
her those powers belong to me we kind of
did a version of this during the Black
Panther movie very Game of Thrones type
story the successor to the crown of
Captain Marvel so if you didn't know
Jude Law is playing marbella obviously
he's gonna be a big character during the
movie they're gonna Steve Trevor the
origin of Captain Marvel probably where
she gets her powers but he winds up
dying in the process but annoy name-drop
quasar people wondering if he's gonna be
a character in the Marvel Universe the
cool thing about file evelle is that she
actually gets quasars quantum bands
which give her like this next-level
power up but she got the bands from
Annihilus who had sort of tainted them
so they sort of poisoned her mind and
she declares war on all sentient life I
also name-drop the Celestials so the
quantum bands of quasar were created by
a celestial called
Eon who is one of the children of
eternity he and the bands show up during
the Captain Marvel Comics so I'm
wondering if we're gonna meet any other
Celestials during the Captain Marvel
movie we'll see if they go that far but
they might save that for future sequels
but hopefully that explains who some of
the villains of the Captain Marvel movie
are let me know who you actually think
will be the real villain like if some of
these are just mr. X but what will
happen is
I have some new Game of Thrones to pose
there's some new flash leave all your
Marvel requests in the comments below
and congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Wyatt aces please
private message me so I can get your
contact details for those of you asking
about Captain Marvel trailers I'm
expecting to start seeing more that
later this year maybe a comic-con
trailer but I'm not gonna hold my breath
for that click here for more new ant-man
and Avengers 4 and click here for my new
Hulk Avengers 4 video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]